welcome back to double rapist to
Scotland named Adam Graham A Center
women's prison last week after
transitioning into a woman named Isla
Bryson beginning of his trial rapist has
now been moved and the Scottish
government's pledgedly announced a pause
on the transfer of violent trans inmates
to women's prisons but Scottish first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon is still
struggling with this issue take a look
at this are all trans women women they
haven't answered that question well
that's not the point that we're dealing
with yeah trans women are women but in
the present context there is no
automatic right for a trans woman there
are context where a trans woman is not a
woman no that is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the male prison
estate is there any context in which a
woman born as a woman will be housed in
the real estate look we're talking here
about trans women I'm now asking about
women born as women I don't think that
our circumstances there uh but it's
different for trans women well yes and
I'm not so they're not equal that is not
that that is a risk assessment process
done for trans women
I mean it's complete and utter gibberish
and this is what happens when when the
woke mindset runs Riot this is where it
leads into complete and utter Insanity
that can't be explained even by the
people spewing it well during today's
pack talk TV contributor Esther cracker
and broadcaster Jenny Cleveland I'm glad
to be joined by daily wire columnist and
a man behind the Smash Hit film what is
a woman Matt Walsh Matt Walsh uh I mean
every time I think this can't get more
absurd this simple question in terms of
a response from women we get something
like that we're a leader of a country
Nicola sturgeon the leader of Scotland
simply incapable of explaining why if
trans women are women then they have to
be kept in male prisons
yeah I mean if there weren't such frauds
and cowards you'd almost feel sorry for
them they backed themselves into this
corner and they're left they're left
with as you said absolute gibberish uh
because that's the that's the
fundamental incoherence at the bottom of
gender Theory it's totally incoherent
and all you have to do is ask some basic
questions and that's revealed by the way
this idea of well we'll do a risk
assessment well look if it was a if
there are female prisoners uh even very
danger if there's an actual female
prisoner who was larger and stronger
you'd have to do a risk assessment there
but there'd be no thought about whether
that prisoner goes to a woman's prison
or not right obviously that prisoner is
gonna be a women's prison
I think you know in a way this this case
has really exposed this whole issue
actually in the most sharpest possible
way because even this rapist ex-wife
came out and said he never mentioned any
of his stuff when they were married for
eight years and she thinks he's invented
the whole transitioning simply to get
himself a cushier a place in a women's
prison where course he would then be
able to prey on women which is what he's
done before which is why he's a
convicted rapist
and I say he because I just don't
believe that he's a genuine transitioner
at all I think he just scammed at
everybody including the legal system
yeah I think he is right and by the way
even if he was a quote genuine
transition right still call him here
because he means man that's what he is
no matter how he feels about himself I
do think it exposes something because at
the heart of this debate whether we're
talking about locker rooms or sports
teams or prisons it's always a question
of first of all what is a quote-unquote
trans woman how do you define it but
then also you have these competing
claims you have the you have the uh the
the the quote-unquote trans person who
says that well if you don't do as I say
it's going to make me feel bad about
myself then you have all the other
people who are affected who say well if
you let them do what they want then we
are going to be unsafe and when you when
you translate this over to a prison and
you're talking about putting violent
predators and sex offenders in with with
with women because if you don't the the
violent Predator will feel bad yeah it's
like okay well we can it's bad it's mad
as is the whole sporting thing well you
have six foot three inch swimmers
pulverizing women born to female bodies
in the pool and breaking all women's
records potentially irrevocably Jenny
can you defend any of this I mean I
think it's a really
Stark example of where this begins to
fall down because prisons are binary and
sex is binary gender is not binary
gender is a is a Continuum but but sex
is binary and whilst there is a kind of
drive to be inclusive and to be
welcoming it gets to a certain point
where when you're conflating gender and
sex when you have a situation where it's
either a male prison or a female prison
that's where this all throws out I'm not
going to try and defend you agree with
me blimey
returning the wokies in real time here
my my point about it is I think the way
you try and introduce you know Limitless
self-identity of any kind yeah this is
where it goes right it goes to insane
places which are actually dangerous this
is dangerous but it's also State
overreach and I feel like no one's
pointed this out because the the state
is not in the business of I'm sorry
accommodating the the needs of trans
identifying prisoners that's not their
business right you can feel how you want
like you said prisons are binary and
they're binary for a reason I went to a
gym this afternoon I was in the female
gym showers I can't imagine a person
born with a penis I.E a male being in
there it's horrifying so I I think even
the fact that you know people feel like
it's a government's business to
accommodate trans prison this is
completely proposal the thing that I
would like to know is I would like to
know where trans men go to prison
nobody's talking about that because
do we talk about trans men and men's
sports do we talk about the difference
biologically the issue only works one
way thank you right biologically in a
swimming pool or sprinting or whatever
it may be people born to male bodies
have an advantage over female bodies
predominantly almost exclusively right
that's why we separated the Sexes at the
Olympics and things there's no Advantage
with it I mean it's not even an
interesting
men go to prison and that would kind of
really shed light on all of this issues
and well you mentioned Jim's uh Esther
when we come back and talk to to Matt
and then you guys about this new
extraordinary viral digital craze of
women shaming men for looking at them in
the gym well the reason Paul said more
than half of men fear being labeled
creepy for talking to women social and
digital influences like Jessica
Fernandez might be partly to blame
tens of millions of people watched a
video shot though from the gym which he
claimed a quote feral man was staring at
her Fernandez has since apologized for
thousands of similar videos are
circulated into huge audiences well back
with my pack and first of all Matt Walsh
I mean you've been following this Matt
it's a quite extraordinary Trend where
from most of the videos I've seen where
people are claiming this is appalling
Behavior it's just blokes in a gym
looking at people I mean but not in any
way that I would describe as predatory
or unpleasant
no of course not this is the trend as
women for whatever reason are recording
themselves at the gym that's the first
problem is if you want to record
yourself working out maybe stay at your
home and do that but then it turns out
this is really a cover to basically
entrap men who might glance over in
their Direction by the way there's
there's a lot of reasons why somebody
might glance at you in the gym maybe one
reason is they find you physically
attractive God forbid it might also be
that I don't know your hogging equipment
maybe you there's equipment that you're
using while you're filming yourself and
muttering to yourself like a
schizophrenic and they want to use that
equipment so they're kind of lingering
around so they can use it those are all
kinds of reasons but this is this
ultimately is why men are paranoid in
just opening a conversation with a woman
obviously I get it the other way I've
started going back to the gym and I get
a lot of very hot women obviously almost
fainting on site naturally when they say
the big guns coming out but um is this a
serious I mean what is going on there
Jerry I think a lot of women feel that
they're being stared at the gym or
having their photo a lot of the footages
aren't you going to gym to make yourself
look aesthetically more you're going to
the gym to exercise what
is
it yeah well I think a lot of women
listen I've heard of many romances that
started at the gym look the thing is I
think we're being too clinical about
this people meet in all sorts of
different settings again like Matt said
you could look at something when I'm
exercising that's you I'd very much like
to be complimented looked at asked out
that's great if anyone is listening but
you know the thing is they can also be
looking at they can also be looking at
you because your form is off right they
could be looking at you because do you
look at other people at the gym yeah if
you're hogging
yeah this is the thing when I go to the
gym I don't think you can avoid looking
at people because I'm looking up to see
what their forms like how they're
carrying certain weights are they
carrying more than me you know male or
female I don't really care I'm just I'm
quite curious about other people using a
gym am I now going to be something
appearing on Instagram influence
influences sites is some sort of perv
well it's possible and look by the way I
also I don't mean to be a victim blamer
here but but could we also say that if
you're a woman and you don't want to you
don't want men to notice you in the gym
maybe wear more than your underwear to
go work out I mean these women whose
videos they're wearing sports bras and
like hot pants I mean how about put some
clothes on if you don't want people to
look at you this is victim blaming no
I'm sorry
I would hear that uh men are afraid of
women laughing at them women are afraid
that men are going to kill them it is
not okay to say that it's a woman's
fault for wearing the wrong you think
the people looking over at people using
some equipment a gym are going to kill
them I think that taking photographs is
threatening staring at people is friends
are these Instagram influencers they are
videoing men taking photographs of them
and listening
um yes uh men please ask away uh Don't
Be Tamed by this boring attitude bad
words thank you back thank you